from jennifer aniston you know that
other great philosopher jennifer aniston
rachel from friends jennifer aniston
just posted
a series of stories to her instagram
talking about how upset she is that
babies in texas won't be killed quite as
often anymore she hates the pro-life
laws she supports
the
uh
abortion industry and she posted a clip
of herself from that absolutely
insufferable show friends and she she
she writes in it i repeat
no uterus
no opinion
so if you're not a woman
you have no right to have an opinion
about abortion
i mention it look jennifer aniston is
not i don't think she's the leading mind
on public matters in this country but a
lot of people say this and we talk about
a lot of other stupid slogans in the
pro-abortion movement this one
may be the stupidest
one now it's becoming outdated i think
jennifer aniston is revealing
how unhip she is because of course we're
now told that
uh non-women can become pregnant men can
become pregnant non-binary you know all
sorts of made-up sexes and genders they
can become pregnant too so that
distinction no longer exists but but
also that even the principle that
unless you
can
perform a certain action you should have
no
you should have no say in that action as
a matter of public policy we don't apply
that to any other aspect of society
right we don't say well and unless you
have tumors you can't make cancer policy
no tumor no
opinion
we don't say well unless you
have murdered someone you do not have
the right to craft laws about murder
well unless you this unless you that
unless you this unless you that no of
course not
we wouldn't do
we wouldn't we wouldn't tolerate that
because
politics refers to the public refers to
public matters not just personal matters
public matters as well
to say nothing of the fact that abortion
involves another person not just you and
not just the mother but also the baby
right so
they repeat these slogans on the left
because they don't have arguments to
make but a lot of people confuse cheap
slogans with arguments and it's
important every so often to remind
ourselves that these things that we hear
that's my body my choice reproductive
rights no uterus no opinion blah blah
blah blah blah blah that
we can
become
i don't know
asleep
we can become unconscious of just how
stupid these arguments are and and the
reason it matters that jennifer aniston
said it is because that show had such
cultural influence i i actually enjoyed
the show when it was on the air i
recently went back and tried to watch it
it's unwatchable it's so terri it's so
trite it is so
wrong like every decision these people
make is just wrong and bad for them and
it's not all that funny even and it's
just so
shallow and in a way in a way it's
actually quite radical but that's how
the establishment pushes their agenda
okay very important to see through these
things it's very very difficult you know
in a world where where the entire
establishment is pushing these shallow
messages i'm so glad you like that clip
stop what you're doing
ring the bell subscribe that way you'll
get notifications for the whole episode
of this podcast
also if you want to avoid the
big tech censorship that has been pretty
crazy lately head on over to apple
podcast spotify or google play wherever
you get your podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show that is
t-h-e-m-i-c-h-a-e-l-w-l-e-s-s-h-o-w
click subscribe leave a five-star review
appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
you